[Music]
people have cut down trees because they
need fuel people have cut down trees
because they need construct homes it is
important that people do have access to
forest and timber resources but this
needs to be on a sustainable basis as we
go towards the development of our
country we need power we need for our
training processing facilities we need
power for different activities most
industries we need perform or centralist
our restaurants most of the things we
are buying recently they need to
charging you need 3 days you need for
energy needs everything is running on
power so far is basically immunity now
our day-to-day lives we have the land
and we have the climate where trees can
grow there are for growing our own
resources input substitution is just a
clear case importing means we are
spending precious dollars to bring in a
resource that we can readily produce at
home action is needed now action was
needed actually yesterday in terms of
getting people to invest in plantations
getting people to plant a tree plant
fruit trees put up a small woodlot and
getting the national consciousness
raised on the importance of maintaining
the watersheds or maintaining the
biodiversity of our remaining few
natural forests
[Music]
the whole process begins with the mother
garden I'm go to your big mother garden
about 20,000 drumettes and that's where
I we pick our cuttings we raise about
500,000 500,000 siblings Emily they are
using a rooting hormone to stimulate the
looking alpha 3 must and will be bad
enough for planting out into the field
plantations were very very important to
my upbringing my family my brothers and
sisters it was the source of all school
fees and so if you planted a belt of of
transitions around natural forests you
are in one way protecting the natural
forest and directly contributing to
tourism and to the wide life they are in
and even up to now my parents have sold
firewood small bit by bit but today I'm
everyday we have sold timber and
remember we don't have a big piece of
land our land is about five acres and
that's where I will grow food that's
where we stay that's where we have
everything in my village a tree let's
say eucalyptus of eight thirteen years
ranges between 80,000 and 120 thousand
part three and if you can imagine most
of the school fees for average schools
is about three hundred thousand to six
hundred thousand so that means every
time five trees can pay fees for a child
this forest up went reduce the oxygen
which is utilized by the you might be
for inspiration this is our excuse me
I've been here for seven years as a
school leader we have managed to produce
over 1,000 professionals Sandra you run
very fast until the water to come and
open for us the generator room being a
rural best school and fat-rich school we
don't have power here and indeed Power
has been one of the highest number one
challenge of the screen so this is the
generator that we are using now that is
a petrol powered generator
Iranian a simpleton or aroma yoga in
dabit tag it was so a union worker now
foot I knew right away Rocco a guru who
knew footing rested enough when you
observe it there and avatar you are an
Arab and a new forest company Chindi
gotten angry on kono Gwangju boot
umbrella Moochie Apple we need above
your aluminum hood when an emo guy JJJ
physiology
[Music]
[Applause]
planting trees is not a choice that can
be debated the country needs its forests
so it is clear that forests are a
necessity for the country it is not a
luxury that we can easily import once
things go wrong I believe in it niffle
is not just a job I'm a Ugandan true and
not all of us have the luxury of getting
on a plane and relocating somewhere else
so we both make things work here we have
to make the same one here
[Music]
you